here it is again so many of you last  year took advantage of this 30 40 50  wines last year  um 20 wines all for eleven dollars and  eleven cents this was Insanity big  article Link in my bio  up on Tick Tock and Instagram and  everywhere LinkedIn I'm posting this  everywhere because this is the single  time of year if you don't buy wine all  year you should buy a case of this  because you're getting ridiculous wines  for 11.11  highly recommend it uh can't imagine how  many people are gonna be pounding wine  techs for this this is the biggest sale  of the year in my dad's Universe  um the best value wine deal I think  going and uh and for parties and and for  holiday gifts and just to have wine  around the house for the year like this  is real wine to level not the crappy by  the supermarket or liquor store